things are looking up for demi lovato on
her road to recovery yes this is music
to our ears
a source tells ET that demi is in a
great place right now and she's being
extra cautious about a recent exit
through rehab which is great news hey
guys i'm courtney teza no and I'm Katie
Crabb well it seems like Dimmie is
getting back into her old routine she
was spotted out looking healthy on
Wednesday after leaving the gym in LA
girlfriend looks amazing as always
radiant yes as always the source told ET
that she is a sober coach right now
she's working out she's eating healthy
know what I mean yes and she's spending
time with people who are good influences
on her life which is what I love to hear
right now right we all need that good
support system and her ex Wilmer
Valderrama is reportedly one of those
people he continues to be a massive
support in her sobriety and here's the
thing about Wilmer he has always been a
consistent source of support for demi
lovato she talked about him in her
YouTube documentary last year I mean
she's talked about him a lot and he's
shown up whenever she needs him I mean
when this apparent overdose happened he
was one of the first people to visit her
at the hospital yeah and again in rehab
yeah and we know that they are very
friendly exes of course they broke up in
2016 after six years together but it's
nice to see that they're still
supporting each other they're still
friends I mean that's what everyone
wants yeah and you know what we've
always heard that we've had multiple
sources say they have a strong bond they
have a strong connection he's always
there for her and I love seeing that
yeah I mean you don't have to be
together romantically to love one
another and of course Demi has always
been vocal about how important he is
we've said said before it's in the
documentary yeah you guys take a look I
do have moments where it's late at night
and I'm lonely and I wonder if
I made the right decision because love
is a gamble I don't know if I'll lose
him for the rest of my life so here's
what we know Demi is currently splitting
her time between a halfway house and an
LA residents we saw that she got out she
voted earlier this week Oh yep she broke
her silence on social media use her cart
her platform for a good cause we just
love that yes but here's the thing her
recovery plan does have addiction expert
dr. Drew a little bit surprised take a
look at what he told us I was reading
though that she's only spending three
days a week there though which is a very
bizarre sort of an idea I mean you're
either in or you're out so I don't know
what that's all about
now Debbie knows sobriety she knows what
she needs to do and I'm sure she's gonna
do fine so this doesn't shock me that
dr. Drew feels this way he has said that
multiple patients that go into rehab
they stay at a sober house about nine to
12 months after completely which to me
makes more sense you need a little bit
more time to get you know get everything
together and get back on your feet in
and jump back in the spotlight yeah
which is exactly what he said that she
needs to surrender to this process now
but here's the thing this is not new for
Demi Lovato she's always been vocal
about her struggles she knows the steps
that she has to take to get to where she
wants ready and she's working hard for
it we know this
so obviously Jimmy is someone that's
taking control of her sobriety and we
love to see the chief you know remaining
clean it makes us so happy but do we
think that her leaving rehab as dr. Drew
suggested is too soon I don't know we
want to keep that conversation going
yeah and here's the thing for me I don't
really think it's for any of us
including dr. Drew to judge this is a
personal journey this is something that
Demi has struggled with for years yeah
and she knows the program she knows the
steps that she needs to take and it's
our job of course to report the news to
you guys yep and your order yeah we just
want to support Demi we want to give you
positive updates when we see her out and
about looking happy and healthy and we
just want to keep this conversation
going and keeping you guys informed so
let's send that support to Demi Lovato
and until next time of course we have
your pop culture fix bad guys